another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr bright is not  permitted to assign the designation over  9 000  to any anomalies dr bright is to be  reminded that first of all the scp  foundation does not track the power  levels of any of its anomalies as that  is a completely subjective notion adding  it's over nine thousand  two official foundation documents is  distracting and confusing particularly  when applied to entities like scp-999  who have no interest in combat second of  all he should know that joke hasn't been  relevant in over a decade he's  embarrassing himself and none of the new  research assistants even know what he's  referencing finally he's not as good as  doing the vegeta voice as he thinks he  is update your references dr bright  you're better than that maybe